hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
how can liquid biopsy help in the
management of patients with liver cancer
i am marie stone of labrutz and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by agilent to learn more visit
agilent.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
dr augusto villanueva assistant
professor at eiken school of medicine at
mount sinai new york
dr villanueva you may now begin your
presentation
thanks for the introduction and and
thanks for the organizers for inviting
me to give this webinar
on on you know one of my main interests
which is the role of liquid biopsy for
the management
of liver cancer
these are my disclosures
i will
include a discussion of one of
our patents at the end of the
presentation
so this is the outline of what i will
discuss in the next 40 to 45 minutes
first i will give you an introduction of
what are the clinical needs for about
cellular carcinoma or atc which is the
most frequent form of primary liver
cancer
and after that i will specifically
discuss what i think would be the role
of liquid biopsy for improving early
detection approaches for this malignancy
and
to derive biomarkers of treatment
response which is a clinical and need
that hasn't been addressed properly for
patients with about cellular carcinoma
so to start a little bit of introduction
of what liver cancer is
here you have a summary of the estimated
number of new cases an estimated number
of
new deaths per year
in the different tumor types
so
as you can see the number one in terms
of incidence and mortality is lung
cancer
and liver cancer is around the fourth in
terms of mortality the size of the dot
represents the lethality of malignancy
so the bigger the dot the the more
lethal is that tumor type for instance
packard is mostly for malignancy and
liver cancer is the second most lethal
tumor
we know that in terms of
incidence and and trends throughout the
last
decade liver cancer has increased both
in mainland and females here summer has
a summary of new cases of different
tumor types in the united states between
2009 2013 so it's big data but you know
the more recent data is very similar
despite liver cancer is not among the
the top in terms of actual number of
cases if you look at trends and then
changes in incidence is the number one
or the the tumor type that has increased
the highest in terms of new cases for
both main and female
liberty has a number of singularities
that that makes it
kind of
a unique two more compared to other
solid malignancies
and one of them is that it's very rare
to develop hcc
liver cancer in a healthy liver
that's as opposed to you know colorectal
cancer or breast cancer
where most patients have a healthy organ
in hcc most patients have some sort of
liver disease the majority of them will
have cirrhosis
now if you look worldwide the prevalence
of the incidence of atc or liver cancer
parallels to the prevalence of incidence
of chronic liver disease for instance
here in asia east asia
and sub-saharan africa you see a lot of
bread because a lot of cases of liver
cancer associated mostly to infection
with hepatitis b virus
china is one of the number one countries
in terms of incidents and is estimated
around eight to nine percent of the
population is infected with hepatitis b
that's a huge risk factor for
development of liver cancer
in egypt the most
so most of the patients have hepatitis c
related htc has 14
percent of the population is believed to
be infected with these virus the number
one country in the world in terms of
incidents in mongolia with 80 cases per
hundred thousand inhabitants of very
high incidence of the birkenstock and
one of the major causes of death in this
country
in the u.s and in western europe the
estimated prevalences are on average is
between 10 to 12 cases per 100 000
inhabitants
as i mentioned before is very rare to
develop a2c in the lack of chronic liver
disease the main causes of
liver cancer and
as an extension of chronic liver disease
or hepatitis b but atc alcohol abuse
disorder and non-alcoholic fatty liver
disease which is increasing dramatically
in western countries
so when patients get any of these causes
for chronic liver damage and they reach
the stage of cirrhosis the risk of atc
increases to one to three percent per
year
now
that is the rationale to recommend
surveillance programs in this patient so
all every zebratic patient should be
enrolled in astrobains program that
includes an abdominal ultrasound and
also heat to protein measurement every
six months
there are some patients who can develop
hcc before the stage of cirrhosis and
that poses a significant problem because
since these patients are not involved in
surveillance because the prevalence or
the incidence of the tumor is very long
these patients when they are diagnosed
the likelihood of these two must be in
at later stages higher
that limits our possibility to cure
these patients
as i mentioned before the current
recommendation for surveillance in atc
abdominal ultrasound and the
quantification of ceremonial protein
every six months and this has a
sensitivity of six to six percent for
the detection of early stage tumors
based on these methanolysis
it's interesting to see that alpha fetal
protein the only cerebral marker that is
recommended for surveillance
is quite old actually the first report
dates back to 1970. so after 50 years
we've been unable to derive new
biomarkers that are good enough to
detect patients in early stages when
they can be potentially here
we have an additional singularity in hcc
is that
to diagnose patients we don't need a
tissue biopsy
so a patient with cirrhosis that has
the typical imaging features of
nodules in the liver so you have a ct
scan of a cigarette liver the patient
has a societies and you have to see
these nodules in all the verb
they are hypervascular in the therial
phase and the washout in the venous
phase this is enough to diagnose this
patient with vasocellular carcinoma so
that's very convenient for patients
because facilitator things but the
downside is that
this limits our access to tissue
biopsies to run biomarker studies and
that has been an endemic problem in atc
research
so when you look at the clinical
management of these patients
this is the bclc stadium algorithm
that classifies patients in five
different stages and provides a specific
treatment recommendation for these
patients it's approved by the american
and european guidelines
for the clinical management of patients
with vital cellular carcinoma
most of the changes that have happened
in the last 10 years in terms of the
clinical management of these patients
have been at patients with advanced
stages
so 10 years ago
more than 10 years ago in 2008 or 2007
the first systemic therapy was approved
for
hepatocellular carcinoma is ceraphony
and after 10 years of negative trials in
the last five years an additional eight
new compounds have been approved by the
fda for the management of these patients
and they're listed here actually some of
these drugs are now being tested at
earlier stages now the problem is that
the majority of the trials that were
testing these compounds were running
part of it
there's a little
a little confusion on which is the best
sequence of therapy that patients should
perceive
to maximize clinical efficacy
and minimize potential toxicity
since there are no biomarkers approved
this is kind of a
those the question of you know what is
the first line best option what's the
second line how patients should receive
immunotherapy they have received already
you know that is against individuals so
there's a little bit of
interest in developing
tools or or
you know
evidence that could
guide physicians on the best way to
allocate and sequence these therapy
there is only one biomarker that has
been approved for the management of a2c
remember we talked about alpha fetal
protein in the early
phases of the disease as it's also
recommended for early dictation well it
was a number of there were two clinical
trials that showed that patients with
advanced states htc with high afp levels
they
increase they have they do well with
ramos serum which is a monoclonal
antibody
so this is only the only instance where
a biomarker can tell you if patients
will benefit significantly from a given
intervention or given drug if the
patient has this biomarker in this case
with high levels of asp more than 400
the the field or the
let's say the management of a2c changed
significantly
last year so this is the result of the
randomized phase iii trial that was
testing
the combination of a test of isomath
plus bypass issue map versus russian
first line for patients advanced stage
atc
and and the relevance of these studies
is twofold the first one is that for the
first time after almost 12 years you
have a drug in this case it was a
combination of testosterone plastic
systema that outperforms for after it
was better improved survival compared to
swaras and faces with advanced stage and
that was a i mean until that trial
nobody could was able to do that
and the second major thing about this
study is that for the first time it
shows that a combination
of in this case an initial point
inhibitor and an antigenic drug is
highly effective in patients with htc
what is striking is when you look at
response data approximately
from 30 percent of the patients treated
with a combination will have an
objective response as opposed to ten
percent of the tree of glycerate
so now i have again we have this
combination therapy that is
very effective in at least 30 percent of
the patient because we know that these
30 of the patients otherwise will do
relatively well
over time
so this is a summary of the landscape of
biomarker needs in hcc
we talk about
risk of htc development so again
patients for instance with non-alcoholic
fatty liver disease they're at risk of
developing acc but the risk is very very
small now the number of patients with
non-qualified liver diseases it's very
high in the u.s estimated to be 80
million so it would be great to have a
tool that would tell us which are those
patients that are hiring that would
definitely benefit
from surveillance programs for early
detection we talked about alpha feta
protein ultrasound that is relatively
poor its performance
also for diagnosis and prognosis we can
improve and certainly the second means
that i think is more relevant is
treatment response prediction so
what how can we better
assign treatment options based on the
probability of the patient responding to
that specific treatment
now their only afp is recommended for
early detection and for
selection of patients that will benefit
from grammar superman
let's move we'll get to the next um
the second part of the presentation what
i will discuss in a little bit more
detail what i think is going to be the
role of
liquid biopsy in the management of
patients
with htc
for those of you who are not familiar
with this concept
the device entails the analysis of two
more components that have leads to the
bloodstream
or any other biological fluid but we'll
focus on most of the people is working
with liquid biopsy in the blood
there are three major components
from the tumor that are released to the
bloodstream that can be isolated can be
quantified it can be measured what are
the actual tumor cells circulating two
more cells that are the biological
substrate of distant metastases along
with
lymphatic dissemination
second component are ct dna these are
fragments of dna when the tumor cells
die the dna is chopped in fragments of
approximately 150 base pairs and this
has its release to the bloodstream can
be isolated and analyzed
and the third component are exosome
which are small vesicles the content is
variable but mostly they have a small
rnas and it's a system of communication
between cells so you can learn a lot
about
you know understanding the content of
these exosomes on how cells behave and
how they communicate communicate with
each other
now the role of liquid biopsy in a2c has
been a study for these three different
components and each one has its
advantages and its
problems let's put it that way so i
wouldn't say that all of them work for
everything but certainly each one has
its potential role in the management of
patients with hcc
now
when you do when you draw blood
when you draw a tube of blood and you
centrifuge the the sample you get three
components at the bottom you have the
red blood cells that now kind of we're
not using for anything
they have a thin
white layer that is called the buffalo
that has blood cells mostly and then you
have the plasma
now from these uh thin white layer
is when you mostly look like this
sequencing tumor cells and you have the
immune cells so you know monotherapy is
a big thing now in oncology and
everybody's just
trying to identify biomarkers of
responsible therapy and i wonder if
systemic
readouts coming from immune cells in the
blood could be useful there's not much
done in hcc so far but i think it's a
promising source of biomarkers
and in plasma what you have is
ct dna and the vesicles that i mentioned
before for ct dna
the the concentration is very variable
for most of the cases less than 10 of
the dna that is in the blood comes from
the tumor and this is probably an
overestimation slightly less than five
or even less than three percent
because in the blood you can also have
fragments of dna from other cells that
die that are not tumors just normal
turnaround of the cells and you can find
also there so one of the main
challenges is to figure out ways to
discriminate the dna in the blood that
comes from the tumor from the dna that
that comes from
everywhere else
with a caveat that the percentage of dna
comes from the tumor is generally lower
than from from the rest of the body
the average length
of the fragments is between 140 170 and
this is thought to be the
the the part of the energy that is
encapsulated nucleosome
is very stable and the half life is
between 50 to 120 minutes and we know
that based on
you know studies that
took dna
in patients with cancer before and after
surgery when the tumor is completely
removed the concentration of the amount
of tomorrow dna drops relatively rapidly
now if you go back to the natural
history of hcc i mentioned remember that
patients with cirrhosis are at high risk
of developing hypocellular calcium and
the risk is between two to three percent
per year and this was rational
to including these patients in
surveillance programs
now let's put specific numbers to what
this represents in the u.s and this is
data from the united states
there's approximately 600 000 serotic
patients in the u.s
if we assume that between two and three
percent will develop atc every year we
have around eighteen thousand new atc's
per year in this erotic patient
now we know that the performance of the
recommended
tools for early hcc detection that's
ultrasound and afp has a sensitivity of
63
so out of the 18 000 will be able to
detect around 11 000 with the tools that
we have
which leaves us with around 40 of the
cases a little bit over six
thousand six hundred patients that will
not be detected because the tools are
not good enough to identify these
patients
well this is kind of the the ideal
scenario but there's something else that
needs to be computed here
and that's the proportion of patients
with cirrhosis that are actually in draw
in a surveillance program and that is
very low with an estimate
proposed that only 25 percent of the
patients that should be on surveillance
are actually on surveillance
but if we compute that in this figure we
have the six
hundred thousand zerotics the eighteen
thousand that would develop atc every
year
now only 25 percent of them will be
enrolling surveillance programs if we
apply here the performance of the url
detection tools we have that only 16 of
the total amount so around 3 000
patients will be actually detected
given a staggering 84 percent of the
patients 15 000 that would not be
identified because either they're not
involved surveillance or because the
tools are not good enough to detect
early-stage tumors
so here have the two barriers for early
agency detection we need to improve the
accuracy of the tools and we need to
improve to increase implementation of
supplements and we wonder if by applying
liquid biopsy we hit both so we have a
better tool that is more accurate and we
have a method that is simpler that does
not imply a patient going to a hospital
every six months to get an ultrasound so
you have to do that
for years and patients get tired and
there's significant attrition after you
know four or five years basically you
know what what's the point that you know
every time i come here the ultrasound is
fine why should i do that
so if we had a method that is simpler
than that maybe blood says you go to
pharmacy you ship to the central lab and
you get the result
and they increase
or decreased attrition for surveillance
in these patients
now in terms of
what what what is out there what has
been published for early detection using
ct dna
these are the two studies that have been
you know
evaluating this
in hcc the first one is from china
almost 2 000 patients case control
they use these markers
specific cpe sites on detected on ct dna
sensitivity of the training set was 85
was specifically 94. the validation 83
specificity 90 which is outstanding
the second study was done in the u.s in
the mayo clinic very similar design case
control also reported very high data in
terms of sensitivity
around 80 for early stage now both the
study has the same problem
and the problem is that the majority of
patients that they included
majority of patients with hcc that they
included
have um advanced stages they're not at
early stages so when we talk about early
detection you need something that
detects probably two more because the
bottom so the most important objective
the aim of revenge programs is to
increase revival not to detect more
tumors but to detect them to take them
at a point
where you can do something or you can
cure the patient so these two studies
have similar limitations but i know that
they're
trying they're enrolling additional
patients with much more earlier disease
we have been very interested in applying
extracellular vesicle analysis for early
atc detection the field of exercise has
evolved in recent years
um there's a lot of
new knowledge on basically the what's
the content of the of the vesicles
what's in there what's the function of
the vesicles and and something that came
quite common in the majority of the
studies there's significant
heterogeneity in these vesicles the
content in the functional in the way you
can
isolate them and detect them this uh the
perturbed studies in cell where they
they present that kind of a technical
overview of different methods to isolate
analyze and modify cellular vesicles
and for instance here you have a
different methods to isolate vesicles
and the components that can be
detected using different methods are
very
viable and that somehow
justify why some of the studies get not
good reproducibility so maybe the
methods are just looking at something
things that are different another thing
that i find striking from this study was
when they analyzed plasma vesicles
they found that a number of rna products
and and here you have it in green are
mapped to the to the genome so there's
kind of a
black box of contents in terms of
functional potential functional or
potential biomarkers that
was available and then we thought that
that was interesting and one reason but
we launched our study
so we did this study um where we
isolated vesicles using ultrasonic
solution which is a rather dirty way of
isolating
vesicles
from healthy controls and patients with
hcc
we did a number of studies to make sure
that we were isolating vesicles
including western blotting and electron
microscopy
and immunolabeling and nta tracking
analysis so again
we want to make sure that what we
isolate with actually containing the
vesicles and we're not getting
significant noise from other components
with the pilot study existing patients
10 patients with
hcc and 5 controls
we isolated the vesicles and we did rnac
on the continental vesicles and we found
a set of markers of small rna sequences
that were able to accurately
discriminate
patients from controls
here we selected three markers
small rna clusters
that were significantly upregulated in
our hd cases compared to controls now
also underscore the fact that all of our
cases are 85 atc's or early stage hcc
with a medium tumor size of less than
three centimeters
the patients the controls again these
are not healthy individuals these are
patients with chronic liver disease that
are actually enrolled in a surveillance
program so this is the target population
of true pains we had around 100 of them
now when you look at the performance of
our three markers
here you have the performance the
predicted performance of ultrasound and
afp based on the mechanologies that i
told you so 63 of sensitivity and around
83 percent of specificity this is the
core of performance
after um
cross-validation
of our three markers
here you have in yellow or in orange the
performance of half a feet of protein in
our cohort which was you know better
than we expected
and here you have the the performance of
our three markers plus alpha feta
protein which outperform any of the two
with a sensitivity that takes 86 percent
and the specificity of 91 percent
and what we found also is when you
compare the expression of our three
small rna sequences without a physical
protein they were not correlated which
makes sense to suggest that we're
providing complementary information in
terms of detection capacity
for patients with early stage hcc
so in addition of
early detection the second area the
second clinical measure
i think that has the most
future in terms of biomarker development
is biomarkers of treatment response
in patients with advanced stage atc
but here you have a summary of the
current approach for the management of
patients with advanced atc
the combination of a test of dev that i
mentioned before is the first line
they have seraphina golden bat in it
that was previously the first line now
is considered
either second line or first line for
patients that cannot receive a test
additional plasticity map
and then you have a third line options
regraphing cabochons from zero map
evolve map or pembroke
as i mentioned before i'm serial mapping
basins that have high levels of afp
ebola map was recently withdrawn
from from its initial approval under the
accelerator program because as you know
probably you don't know that the the
phase three trials
that were
designed to
confirm the efficacy of nibalma
vampirism were negative
but the fda decided to keep pembroke and
discontinue and evolve in terms of
accelerated approval there's the also
the combination of niboloma
classification
also under the accelerating program
so as i mentioned before when you move
down this algorithm
again it's unclear what would be
the criteria to decide which patients
receive
each of these therapies and clinicians
most of them do is they select the
treatment based on side effect profile
that would be more favorable for a given
patient
or orange analysis but
as you can imagine is not the best way
to select therapies for the inpatient
and we know that patients that are
treated with immunotherapies
and respond they do extremely well so
this is data from the phase 2 trial that
was tested in the bubble map
in patients with advanced htc that was
the basis for the accelerated approval
you have survival according to response
in the green you have patients with
complete or passive responses you can
see here the percentage is not very high
it's around 16 to 18 percent
but they do extremely well
so the median survival so the the half
of the patients that have a response on
eboloma live more than a year and that's
unprecedented for hcc at this stage
so who are these patients right so is
there any way that we can identify the
patients that would respond on the other
way around which are the patients that
we
do very poorly on these therapies
so we try to assess that and we did a
study using
gene expression
on on
tissues from patients with early stage
hcc it was led by dr lovett a while a
while ago
and we found that around 25 of the
patients
um
have what we call the new class and they
have an enrichment of signals that
suggests activation of the immune system
and this can be super classified in
other
classes active and exhausted but the
bottom line is around 25 of the patients
could be classified in this class
there were other group of tumors you
have here the immune class around 30 and
you have other group of tumors around 30
percent but lack any signal of immune
activation not only genomically but when
you look at histologically the tumors
there were no immune cells infiltrating
those two so completely cold
and these are the ones that
you know we call them minus footed and
they were in great mutations of the wind
benefiting pathway
since these patients are at early stages
and this was before the amount of
therapies were available we couldn't
tell whether you know these classes
could be used as biomarkers of response
to immune checkpoint negatives but what
we did is we compare our signatures with
others have been shown to be effective
in other millennia since there was a
significant enrichment so our things
were very similar to the sensors that
identified responders
to these therapies in melanoma lung
cancer
whether that is enough probably not so
we need additional
evidence to support the role of these
signatures to identify patients that
would respond to immune based therapies
more recently
you have the paper on journal pathology
that reports on potential biomarkers of
response from the phase two trial the
development trial that i was mentioning
before
so they run a number of studies on
tissue samples from these patients gene
signatures
and there were some p-values and some
association but for instance when you
look at the
percentage of positive pd-1 cells
according to response you have your
complete response and passive response
to stable disease and progressive
disease there's some p-value there's
differences in terms of the percentage
of p1 positive cells and the one that
responds to the ones that do not respond
but you can see here that you have a
p-value there's significant overlap
between the groups and you cannot use
that in clinical practice you need
something that is much cleaner and much
more clinically actionable to implement
and to recommend guidelines
so we start working on ct dna and the
question was
the first question that we posed a
couple of years ago is
can we detect mutations
in cdna of patients with hcc
so we did this pilot study where we
enrolled eight patients and and
we did ultra ultra deep targeted dna
sequence of all action of a title of 50
atms that we selected based on whether
they were draggable or they were
prevalently mutated in hcc based on
tissue analysis
out of the eight patients we also did
multi-regional sampling in different
regions of the primary tumor and we
found 21 mutations in tissue we have
pure tissue and blood from this cohort
and out of the 21 mutations in tissue 71
we could detect implied
now we confirm these mutations using
digital proper pcr we're quite confident
that we have a tool that at least
detected 31 of the mutations
but this was kind of the old days and
and and
while we were doing this study then the
new technology including barcodes was
was developed and we thought well if we
can increase the accuracy we may do
better to identify biomarkers but they
sent a second study where we enroll
patients
with advanced htc 85 these are the
patients that are not biopsy regularly
remember i mentioned about the fact that
most patients can be diagnosed without
the need of a biopsy so for these
patients we'll have tissue to do
biomarker analysis so we need another
source to identify potential biomarkers
so here in this 85 patients some of them
were treated with tyrosine kinase
inhibitor 24 some of them were treated
with checkpoint inhibitors
but they were all at advanced
states
we reduce the size of the panel for
tanning the reason instead of 58 we did
25 genes again genes that are frequently
made in hcc
or
genes of the wind pathway because we
wanted to test the hypothesis that i
mentioned before that
you know those tumors with mutations
between the containing pathway tend to
be immune excluded so
if that's the case is that a correlate
that would tell us the patients that
were not responsible to neural blood or
immune checkpoint individuals so that's
why we we changed a little bit the panel
and we also we did promote with digital
drop with pcr because
it was kind of difficult and it's always
very difficult to identify the promoted
mutations using ngs so we
kind of use a different assay to
promote mutations
um so we use the shirt select technology
the library says it was 225
and here you have the details of you
know the sequencing approach and how we
call limitations and you can find more
details on the actual paper
so this is a summary of the mutational
landscape of our 85 htc patients
i want to emphasize the fact that these
are advanced hcc advanced stage which is
different to the majority of patients
that have been published and all the
tcgas and icgc that were all using
resection a specimen which is a
different state
the first thing that we know is that for
the majority of genes that we know are
prevalent in early ages they're also
prevalent in advance the most frequently
imitated industrial promoter was 51
the p53 30
beta hitting 17 and as in early stages
betadine and their promoting mutations
are mutually exclusive sorry beta
getting and 50 limitations are mutually
exclusive
as expected when you look at survival or
progression of feast revival based on
response rate so the patients that were
treated with mostly with immunity point
users that respond they do significantly
better than the ones that did not
respond and this was expected based on
previous data
and here you have the characteristics of
our cohort the 38 patient three which
checkpoint inhibitor the 23 treated with
status in canada's emitter the majority
of terrorists against innovators was
seraphini have to say more than 90 and
the majority of checkpoint inhibitors
wasn't evolving up again more than 90
things to highlight is that the cause of
the theology of the liver disease was
multi hepatitis c virus infection
and they were evenly distributed between
both cases even probably a little bit
more of alcohol-related hcc also
in in the in that one that received the
ebola map
then you have the majority as mentioned
before were facing with advanced hcc
they had multiple decision 80 of the
cases and also we found patients with we
have patients with extra batteries
spread in almost half of the two cohorts
the median afp of 100 420 in one case
and 785 all of them above 400 is the
cutoff used to identify patients with
aggressive tumors
so in summary we're dealing with a
cohort of patients with advanced tumors
with aggressive tumors and relatively
difficult to treat
the other results of the patients that
were treated with tyrosinase inhibitor
and the mutation analysis of these
patients we found that patients with
mutations of the of genes belonging to
the pi3k emptor pathway tend to do worse
as opposed to the ones without these
mutations in the patients receiving
trafficking for tkis this did not happen
in patients to use checkpoints
suggesting
that this could be a biomarker
lack of response in this case to
surround it it's interesting because a
couple of years or before we the couple
of years before we published this study
the group was memorial some category led
by jim hardin they also found that
mutations of patients with htc and
mutations in genes of the emptor pathway
they didn't have also response to
thyroid sickness but the main difference
between their study in our study that
they use tissue as opposed to us if we
use blood and ct dna
to call the mutations
when you look at the patient that
received checkpoint inhibitors the
volume up in our case
we found or we did not found that
patients that had mutations in the wind
pathway do worse did worse with
development
actually we had a couple of patient
limitations in beta getting confirmed
mutations
i had very good responses we raises the
question of whether
you know it's not not only the fact that
you need to have the the immune cells
within the tumor but maybe there may be
a role of evolving up or checkpoint
inhibitors to facilitate recruitment of
immune cells within the tumor
and that way increase response to these
therapies
there's another thing that we
introduce introducing this paper that i
think
is by far the most valuable thing about
liquid biopsy
and so most of the people would say
well the number one benefit of the good
biopsy is that you don't need to do a
tissue biopsy that has complications
that is invasive but it's annoying and
that you know
patients are much better doing a blood
test than having to do a tissue biopsy
and that's true and it's a major
advantage
but to me
by far the main advantage of liquid
biopsy is you can do it sequentially
so if we assume and we know for a fact
that tumors evolve over time they change
when they're exposed to different
treatments
they they there's a process of chronic
evolution of tumors and we're
pretty far away from
studying that chronic evolution in real
time in patients
do you think that it's difficult to get
a tissue biopsy from an hcc patient is
almost impossible to get three four five
biopsies from tissue biopsies from a
patient you know before receives the
treatment after receiving the treatment
before progression after progression
that's not gonna happen it's unrealistic
but you can certainly take one blood
sample every time the patient comes to
the clinic so that's the game changer in
my view and that's why i think the
devices will become mainstream
sooner or later for the management or
for to better understand
how tumor evolves and how tumor
interacts with our therapist with the
immune system in a way that we can use
that information to the right biomarkers
we have two examples of a progressive
disease and objective response in three
patients in this case
in our study and also two patients based
on seven seven and eight in the other
part of the figure
and what you can see here is that the
mutations change they change the binding
fraction the prevalence and change the
actual mutations in one patient you see
that a point
there's an emergence of the fifties
limitation that was not present at
baseline
well you can say maybe it was present
you would know you didn't detect it it's
possible
but i i it's not it's conceivable to
this to believe that this patient may
have developed a mutation
you know over time with a new chrome or
part of an evolution of
emergence of a more fit
clone
we have also worked on developing
experimental models to study liquid
biopsy and this is a very
easy approach we inject subcutaneously
nude mice to cell lines that have
different genetic makeup
trying to mirror to mimic heterogeneity
in humans and they were treated with her
affirmative possibilities
that at the time was the drug that was
more
readily used for patients with hcc and
you can analyze the blood of these mice
and the tech mutations
in our case we use the example pcr and
it's kind of an easy way
or a
feasible tool to to study phonodynamics
and how liquid biopsy in this case ct
dna can help us
trace clown composition over time and
then one patient so in this case when
animals are exposed to different
therapies
so just to summary
the presentation i would say that
liver cancer is a major health issue and
and we know that its incidence is
increasing
worldwide in the us in particular
immortality is also increasing
there are specific areas in atc research
whereby biomarkers are needed and i
would like to highlight two of them
early detection the tools that we have
are very poor they they only detect 63
percent of the patients who started too
much we need something that is better
than that because we're missing a lot of
patients with fairly too much they can
be cured
and secondly
biomarkers are needed to tell us which
is the best sequence of treatments a
patient will receive to maximize
efficacy minimize toxicity
we know that
mutation analysis of ctv and identifies
can biomarkers resistant to seraphinate
we show the data of mutations in genes
of
the mtor pftk signaling pathway whether
that could improve trial designs still
to be studied but certainly will help
facilitate the development of mobile
markers using ctdna
i think there's no question that liquid
biopsy has emerged as a promising and
above all a very convenient tool for
biomarker development in hcc and i would
say in oncology in general and there are
number of studies that show its power
to detect you know minimalistic disease
identify patients not on an atc but in
colorectal cancer and
lung cancer
with that i want to thank people in the
lab forming members of the lab that were
leading these studies particularly johan
von felden opposed a very talented
postdoc in germany back in germany that
said the ctv in a study
and the
accelerometer studies along with teresa
of the family that was also very
talented in the lab working on the
circular bicycle study i thank you for
your attention and i'm happy to take any
any questions
thank you dr villanueva for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask
question box located on the far left of
your screen we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
what were your criteria for curating the
25 gene panel used to profile ct dna
samples
yeah so
when we in the first study that we
analyzed the ctdnata pilot we use a
panel of 58 chains and then we decided
to scale it down
first to reduce cost and to be more
selective in the type of information
that we're going to be
achieving so the main criteria will
first look for
prevalent gene so prevalent genes that
are mutated in atc based on tissue
studies
and you know the top
let's say 15 genes have been reported to
be mutated in hcc because we wanted to
know
you know if the mutation profiling in
advanced cases was similar or mirror a
bit what has been reported in early
stages
and the second is one of the the reasons
that we conducted these studies we want
to confirm
or want to test the hypothesis that
patients with mutations in beta-caterini
did not respond to
checkpoint inhibitors specifically in
ebola map so we included a number of
genes five genes that were part of the
beta-catenin pathway non-dopamine atc
and you have to one action two
to specifically address that question so
those were kind of the two main criteria
we follow to to address that
okay thank you
next question
currently is it worth doing research
work on the effect of seraphinib on
hepatocellular sarcona
yeah that's a very interesting question
and
i guess the reason for the question is
um
so six years ago there was only
swarovski approved by the fda and now we
have nine drugs approved so
is is there any role
of seraph and even the management of hcc
so it's worth to invest money and time
to study the effects and the biomarkers
disrupt and i think the answer is still
still yes obviously not as dominant as
it used to be
but you think about it in first line
the recommended therapy is a test of
that
but
in the trial and in clinical practice
patients that have
viruses in the sufferers that's a
complication of cirrhosis you develop
veins in the software that can break so
these spaces cannot be treated with this
combination this represents
approximately 30 of the patients then
this patient would be eligible to be
treated with strategic all and that in
it so still strategy has a role in the
clinical management of agencies it was
not it's not it's not as dominant that
this used to be but i i think that it's
still
a niche
to to keep studying or you know getting
additional information of the role and
potential biomarkers of response to
surrounding
okay thank you
next question
did you test other liquid biopsy samples
like urine for your studies
no that's the short answer and uh
there's no specific reason because there
are studies showing
um that you can quantify some of these
analytes in urine and it's even easier
for patients because you can think about
home collection of samples
but for a number of reasons we focus on
blood but certainly urine or in saliva
are very interesting sources for running
this type of analysis
okay
and next question
excuse me this is a bit of a technical
question with your 225
kbp probes being on the low end
of what the sureselec technology is
designed for
did you have to optimize much to achieve
a low off target coverage
yeah so
i would say that in general
the whole
technical process of generating the data
was relatively straightforward
so we didn't
so there was not a specific need to
you know do a lot of troubleshooting to
generate the data
i i guess that i think that the main
bottleneck on our end is that the
starting material is 4 mls of plasma
which is
good which is kind of a little bit
too much we need we scale it down to 2
ml
but from that point you know the
centrifugation of the sample the
isotopes in the dna and then all the
downstream analysis and then the
data generation pipeline
we didn't have many issues i have to say
hey thank you
next question
did you detect any stromal fibroblast
markers in the liquid biopsy projects
you were involved
or are you aware of any published
reports on this issue
so we did not found any specific stromal
markers so i cannot uh tell you
specifically about that
i i don't know of any specific project
looking at liquid biopsy
surrogates of of the stronghold
component of microbiota but so with in
addition to the bats it was we've also
worked in projects related to hcc
evolution and
heterogeneity and single cell sequences
and and it's
it's amazing the
dominance of the tumor mic environment
in all these studies even when you look
at functional hydrogenated different
parts of the primary tumor so
um i i wouldn't be surprised if it could
be another potential source to detect or
derive biomarkers on
tumor progression or response to therapy
specifically looking at the mic
environment
thank you next question
do you see ctcs one day replacing afp
testing all together
uh i
i think i don't think so
but i will rephrase a little bit the
question do i think
ct dna analysis replacing afb
and and and to be a little bit more
provocative i see ct dna analysis
replacing afp plus ultrasound
in surveillance programs yeah i do think
so i have the city dna or cellular
vesicles based on
what has been published and and
our data i think that they're very
promising not to outperform afp which to
be honest it's kind of a sort of a
relatively bad biomarker
is to replace the whole thing afp plus
ultrasound and that's the that's the
objective that's the aim simplify the
whole terrains
effort and endure blood on blood only
based
tests that is easy to implement that is
accurate that can help us increase early
detection rates for patients with htc
okay
next question
is it possible ct dna can identify
important molecular markers that could
be missed if another tissue biopsy is
difficult to pursue
so i'm not sure i understand the
question
but um
if you're referring to the fact that
so in our analysis we're very
targeted in what we're looking for so we
have 25 genes and
and you could say you could argue well
it's kind of a limited scope of what
you're looking for right
and it's true so you don't have the
coverage of adapting analysis that you
would get with collection sequencing
within the tissue
and you may be missing
you know
information or or
genes that are mutated that could be
relevant that is true but it's always a
trade-off i know there are some studies
don't collect some signals in plasma
um
i think that the the you know there's
some technical issues and may not be
still mature but certainly you can
expand to larger bigger team panels 400
500 genes with very good results like
within less
technology so
and i think that still we kind of focus
on on a small portion of the
story of potential genetic alterations
in hcc
but i found that by collecting that at
least we get some information without
the need of doing a tissue biopsy
okay thank you
next question
can you comment on your method of cf dna
extraction in typical yield
yeah so as i mentioned before the one of
the main is not an issue but something
that we would like to improve is that
the input amount of plasma that you need
is relatively high
four mls ideally but then scale it down
to two mls
but the the process is relatively
straightforward there are a couple of
runs on centrifugations
and then we use commercial available
kids to extract the
cf
security free dna
um so the concentration that we obtained
and we did this both in plasma and in
serum to see if the yield or
or the performance of mutation calling
in these two compartments was different
and we didn't find any differences so
you can use either plasma or serum at
least for our study the median
concentration that we detected was
around 10 nanograms per ml which is low
but they're tools that can handle that
low amount of dna
okay
next question what is the treatment for
liver cancer in advance
so
if you're referring to
liver cancer at advanced stages is there
are a number of systemic therapies that
have been approved
um
specifically there are eight drugs
compounds approved by the fda
and that's essentially the mainstay
without going into much details
if you're talking about
prevention of hcc so let's say that you
have a patient with cirrhosis and you
know that the patient is at increased
risk of developing hcc so why don't we
give the patient something to prevent
civil cancer development
so there has there have been a number of
trials testing different compounds
vitamin a analogues
so roughly was tested to prevent
recurrence
vitamin k retinoids and and none has
proved to be effective to prevent agency
development so there are no approved
drugs in chemo prevention for hsa
i see
next question
what is the best way to stimulate mice
hepatocellular sarcoma in a short time
so if you're asking which is the best
animal model in terms of
you know
which is the one that more quickly will
develop htc
so obviously the the
fastest on on our hands was
the succudence injection of
cell lines which is in immune mice which
is not the best for a number of reasons
but it's certainly very quick the other
model that we've used not for the liquid
biopsy studies but for other projects is
hydrodynamic television injection of
genetic elements that gets get delivered
to the participants directly
and and and that's very convenient
because you can let's say manipulate the
number of genes you're going to use
typically mutations penetrate the
mutations make over expression
and and you can get tumors
in the liver so orthotopic models in
three to four weeks which is very very
quickly
when you go to chemical induced models
en ccl4
those take significantly longer so
depending a little bit on what type of
project that you're interested in you
can use the different approaches but you
can have models developing
hcc as short as three four weeks
thank you
next question what was the sequencing
depth used in your ct dna study and
variant allele frequency detection
limit achievable
with the sequencing depth
yeah so on average the the depth of
sequencing was between five thousand to
ten thousand x um depending on the you
know the two studies that that we did
and the vaf of the so detection limited
was point one percent i have to say that
for most of the
mutations that we detected the baf was
around one percent remember that i
mentioned
in the presentation that less than ten
percent
of the
you know dna in the blood comes from the
tumor
well you have outlier patients that the
percentage is high but the majority of
the patients were around one percent
which is what you know complicates a
little bit the analysis
and when you're when you're working with
ct dna
okay well it looks like we have time for
one more question
did you use umi to sequence cf dna
and can you comment on the importance
and necessity of using umi
so in the two in the first study uh you
know the pilot study where we did the
pair samples tissue and blood from the
htc patients we didn't use uni particles
and one of the problems that we have is
that we have a significant number of
false positive calls so variants that we
detected that were not true mutations
but
uh sequencing errors so with umi is you
reduce that dramatically and it was at
the end of a big advantage in the second
study where we did apply umis and the
number the percentage of false positive
calls was significantly lower so i think
that at this stage it's
it's very difficult to do a
comprehensive study and and
get reliable information at the city dna
space if we're not using barcodes or
umis
thank you dr villanueva do you have any
final comments for our audience
no i hope that you enjoy the
presentation and you see that okay
biopsy certainly
moving forward as a potential new tool
for the management of patients in
wisconsin in general with hsc in
particular i think there's still
some
you know additional problems that need
to be sorted out but i certainly see
that's the future for the management of
patients with agency
thank you again dr villanueva for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor agilent for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions you do not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye